لكن مشاهدينا دعونا نتعرف على هذه المواقع
السريه والتي يشتبه الغرب بانها مصدر
لانشطه نوويه مشبوهه في ايران لدينا في
قريه تركز اباد التابعه لبلده كهرزك ضمن
مدينتي شهرري في جنوب محافظه طهران وتصدر
اسم هذه القريه اخبار العالم عندما اعلن
بنيامين نتانيا في كلمه له في الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده ان
ايران بمنشاه سريه في هذه القريه وفي
الخامس من ابريل 2019 فتشت الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه هذه القريه اباد
واعلنت رويترز في سبتمبر 2019 نقلا عن
الدبلوماسينا غربيا العثور على اثار
اليورانيوم همم هناك اما في موقع ماريوان
هذا الموقع الثاني يقع بالقرب من مدينه
اباده بمحافظه فارس جنوبيه ايران
كشفه عن هذا الموقع بواسطه منظمه المجاهدي
خلق المعارضه التي قالت ان الحكومه
الايرانيه اجرت عده تجارب للاسلحه النوويه
في ذلك الموقع الذي يخضع للحارس الثوري
الايراني اما الموقع الثالث فهو في مدينتي
وربين التي تقعوا الى جنوب شرقي العاصمه
طهران وبخصوص اكتشاف اثار اليورانيوم هناك
في موقع بورمين والتغيرات التي طرات على
مبانيها الموقع قالت ايرانينا اعاده بناء
المبنى في هذا الموقع لا يمكن اعتباره
انشطه تنظيف لاثار اليوريا
[موسيقى]